voters lining up to cast their ballots
in new hampshire
this is one of the states that will be
watched closely as the results come in
most agree that if democrats lose here
their prospects of holding on to the
senate will diminish
many think it could go down to the wire
i think it's going to be a very tight
race but i think that this is what it's
all about to be able to vote
and have a voice and hopefully select
the
people that you think are going to
represent the state the most
appropriately
i'm hoping we could have some of these
republicans in the
senate so we could get the votes going
but democrats such as kay hagan of north
carolina another key state
are determined to stop the republicans
from winning a majority in the senate
she has been campaigning until the last
minute doing all she can to encourage
traditional democrat supporters
like young women and minorities to turn
out i've got a
hundred locations across north carolina
right now
with ten thousand volunteers hitting the
pavement
knocking on doors reminding people the
difference in this race
and the importance of exercising our
constitutional right to vote
but the republicans already sent success
and most polls appear to be on their
side
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
says a republican victory would have
far-reaching consequences
we could have for the second time in our
history the majority leader of the
senate
setting the agenda for america and
taking us in a new direction
president obama and his advisors are
playing down the impact of a republican
takeover of the senate
but a victory there would give the
republicans control of both chambers of
congress
and some say make life even harder for
obama in the last two years of his
presidency